snitch on the toast but I'm thumb snitch
on the toast Oh snitch on the toast put
up bum snitch on the toast wow that was
such a good one it felt really good it's
just been a while since we lost did it
right over to girls who really can't
sing for the life of them I think we
really pulled it off I think we've
really mastered the art of harmonization
I think we've really mastered the art of
snitch on the toes oh yes yeah for sure
but it's crazy because we haven't had a
snitch on the toast situation in a while
you know while like and you know we love
to twit and first snitch on the toes so
of course today we are twinning in our
headbands this headband was my birthday
gift from the snitch last night such a
sweet gift I'm still figuring out how to
wear it like it's definitely a dramatic
look for sure no because we were trying
to make it look more normal in and then
it's like it's not a normal item it's
not a normal item like it's supposed to
have a dramatic vibe so I'm just going
with the drama today yeah and the snitch
just showed up and showed out because
Jackie was like texting me like barking
orders at me yes last night
imagine of what to wear it was two
things I don't remember but one of them
was to wear a headband and so I was like
okay you're the only one that I have
today we're mrs. headband we're mrs.
head because we'd love to twin
personnage on the toast and you look
just look so incredible today thank you
because when you're on the snitch cam
like no offense you look like a pile of
Doody oh of course because it's just my
face all I need to do is wear makeup no
I know but you just really brought out
all the guns today you have your blogger
boots on my blogger I'm so sore I can't
even lift them because they're so heavy
but my blogger boots we are still so
sore from the live method on Monday oh
my who's Monday I thought it was Tuesday
no it was Monday oh my god like I can't
even go upstairs and wearing these
blogger boots is just it's just not
working for me because I have to move a
lot more than I have that I'm used to
yeah it's tough stuff and yesterday was
my birthday it was such a fun day we did
something so crazy and we worked out on
my birthday oh yeah what's wrong with us
nobody was great and there was such a
feast II vibe dinner yeah we did dinner
was delish dinner was delicious and like
I don't feel heavy
I thought it I don't feel heavy either
do you think it was because we did
SoulCycle like yeah as opposed to laying
on the couch all day eating starbursts
and watching the worst hallmark movie
we've ever seen in our life it was just
it was just so rude it was called the
spruces in the pie
and it had the makings for an incredible
film oh my god it was such a good like
plot such a good idea such a good plot I
liked the actress on her own because
she's from my favorite hallmark movie um
a feeling of home and it liked the actor
he was so cute but just all together it
was a big fat there was absolutely no
chemistry I actually don't like that
actress but I know that you like her sex
with her but she took part in one of my
favorite homework movies so I have no
choice but to stand like Brooke d'Orsay
just needs to be in every single film
and it'll be it'll be good I know it'll
be golden it will be golden but she's
probably just so busy that she can be in
every movie I really don't think she's
that busy no but like she's busy doing
hallmark she can't be in every home I
gotta follow her on interim see what
she's up to
yeah and then you can catch the flicks
that she's in right catch the flicks
catch the flicks so we did till say go
which was actually a great class it was
Ariana Grande neighbors Maggie Rogers
and it was very seedy it was very CNE
honestly I was living for the mirages
looking for that I was already songs I
didn't know of hers I just liked them
yeah and he played I'm good as hell the
remix with re so we got a little list oh
so it's just a great it was a great
class oh my god and they brought me a
candle at the end and like it was just
so uncomfortable because they always
bring like a birthday candle for when
it's someone's birthday and of course
like for me they like not on time so
like the instructor had to go out and
remind them and then like it was just so
I know you stretch oh so I got back on
the bike and it was just like that's the
kind of like painful encounters that
only happened to me that's the
difference between Instagram versus
reality it's like when you posted your
story like people were like oh my god
like this so keep like in reality is the
most uncomfortable thing ever I knew
like grabbed me into the photo I think
out of discomfort discomfort but also
like I want to give my photo idea this
class alone no that's true and it made
for a cuter photo shoot for me being
like a big dope on the bike I can't it
was just so awkward it's fine it was
fine
so yes I'm officially 27 now and life
goes on how does it feel it feels great
I got great presents that we'll just
carry me through the year and just
remind me of you know what I mean to
everyone and how you went out of your
way to find this beautiful headband I
did go out of my way to find that
beautiful head and it's just a symbol of
our relationship it really is you know
every part of myself every time I look
at it I'm gonna smile
yeah I just got like such great gifts
from all of my loved ones and it was a
very cheery day it really was better
cheer day I had a great day yeah we
spent the whole day together yeah the
one minute we spent apart she posted on
Instagram because it's like so awkward
if you're like posting for someone on
Instagram like writing a whole thing in
like you're with them and sync you're
just like secretly typing in and like
the blog they're supposed to go to their
phone and see in like you're literally
sitting next to each other so I just did
it all day and then I was like starting
to feel bad it's like I know like things
like that are important to you which
like they're important to me so it's no
shade and so then the second I like got
into a cab to leave you I posted it so
it's just like I don't know when I'll
have this time again well it's important
to me because it's important to you so
it's like because I do that for you it's
important that you do it back for me no
pressure so it was such a nice post the
campers all of them got a shout out last
night Russian camper was born with this
headband which is cool it's like cos
it's the second cousin and he goes to
camp now and it's pretty cool she chose
him yeah she she she's he's she
he's a shame yeah very exciting so the
campers are expanding the counselors on
the toast the snatchler is back in
business I'm so excited you're here
today because we've talked about on the
morning toast how the snatchler is
bachelor yes yes it's back and it's just
such an exciting time and I just want to
get into it a little bit more because
the first episode is taking the world by
storm it really is of Mike Scioscia I
literally felt like people are gonna be
like wow these girls are so annoying
they say like so much they are saying
that that part but still but that will
get better yeah you will learn you hear
yourself and Ukraine oh my god and then
you won't do it again I'm learning so
many things Clady and I have gotten so
much better we still have obviously a
long way to go but I feel as though we
do say like less than we did in the
beginning right oh my god every other
breath was like and I curse a lot too
just like there's a lot to really like
adds emphasis to what you're saying so I
don't really know if it's a bad thing I
think a lot of times it adds emphasis
but sometimes it takes away because it's
like oh you're just throwing in swear
words because your point isn't that
strong you know okay
that's what but then sometimes it's like
no right it's [ __ ] out of my face ho
yeah exactly sound the same is good to
get out of my face ho no get out of my
face woman right alright yeah so I'm so
excited this natural er is back sure I
can't say without saying it
how are you feeling about everything I'm
feeling good about it like as long as
people like it and keep listening I'll
keep doing it but up until until that
stops going constant you're gonna like I
saw so many comments from people who are
like it's just nice to hear like normal
girls on a podcast and you talk about
your work and also what a little tidbit
I found so interesting in an episode was
when you and Nicole were talking about
jobs and she was talking about making
friends in the office yeah and you guys
were so cute and it's really true you
were like well are you supposed to make
friends at work isn't everyone out to
get each other and it's like that is
what we are meant to believe right also
it's not totally untrue like these are
your co-workers they're also your
competition it doesn't always have to be
that way right but you do have to like
sleep with one eye open right so it was
an it was just you guys were touching on
some interesting workplace dynamics and
I found to be well interesting ya know
that's a lot of like our the point of
the podcast is just to be like as
relatable as possible I think and that's
kind of why we're doing it cuz like we
said now the cloudy's not here to yell
at me for saying it we're trying to
build our own audience of like Gen Z
like post-grad like people who are like
my age and are just as confused as I am
and have as much anxiety as I am and so
we're just trying to harp on that and
you know build into what's the word it's
tap into that market ooh look at this
snatchler she is such a marketer well
it's gonna be great we're so excited for
you just keep on keepin on we believe in
you over here at tiene thank you for
giving me the platform give the utmost
faith in this natural er wow that's just
such an honor well we have a great show
for you today we've got some great
stories the snatchers here campers are
here everyone's here
open chambers here today oh I mean I
think all of the campers really except
for Italian because she just like never
[ __ ] shows up for her counselor
that's her cross to bear like she's out
of control
but American obviously Russian obviously
French she's little less a fair but
Irish Oh Irish thanks so much great
thanks a lot my crotch is that tied to
Nami iPad because it's caught used to
your iPad instead of mine it's not
charging my iPad and it's all your fault
yeah IRA she's here she's a little angry
in the other room yeah she's always
angry in the other room but the
all here so I think without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast but before I let you do that it is
my great privilege to let you know the
today's episode is brought to you by
ShoeDazzle ShoeDazzle is a wonderful
online platform wonderful that here at
the toast we love I know that Margo
loves it as well I do because you can
get on trend fashion at an irresistible
price also I just realized that my shirt
is from ShoeDazzle today honestly I keep
wearing things realizing that it's from
ShoeDazzle like that neon orange chunky
sweat shirt I wear every single day she
dies on it honestly usually Claudia does
the read so I didn't realize said today
was she does until I got hearing him so
I didn't even plant I said how much you
got as ShoeDazzle
is a part of my life yeah they have chic
inclusive impulsive and extroverted
styles for that extroverted woman or
introverted it works where you take a
style quiz for a personalized outfit
recommendations you can shop over a
thousand different styles it's true I
took my quiz they give me styles and you
know it takes me a while to find
something like I'm dying for but there
are so many pages have like load more
load more I find what I'm looking for in
an instant check out as a guest or
become a VIP as a VIP you get 30 to 50%
off regular place prices plus free
shipping on orders over $39 so we're
like and I feel like this is something
that you're gonna experience but like as
women we're expected to like stroll into
work like looking so glamorous in new
clothes and it's like where are we
supposed to get all of these items no
time most ShoeDazzle it makes it so easy
because you have all of like these
wonderful options at such affordable
prices and you can really like be on
trend at all times so ShoeDazzle is
offering our listeners an exclusive deal
get your first shoe dazzle style for as
low as $10 as a VIP at 75% 75% off your
first item with our special link just go
to shoe dazzle dot-com slash toast to
take advantage of this deal now that
ShoeDazzle comm slash toes to get your
first style for as low as $10 as a VIP
you can also get free shipping on orders
over $39 and there's absolutely no
commitment when you purchase your first
order that ShoeDazzle dot-com slash
toast so I love ShoeDazzle I've gotten
so many clothes a top that I'm wearing
right now that's just
a great top and every time I wear it on
the toast I get so many compliments that
actually is a really great time
right because it's technically a basic
it's like a black long sleeve but the
there's some character the arms give it
drama and it matches that drama of the
headband of course so I love everything
I got from ShoeDazzle great for basics
great for trendy items great for life
great for life sign-on look amazing
sign-on dazzle sign-on dazzle snitch we
got to give you a job oh wait wait okay
are you ready for the first story
because it's am i gonna know what's
going on today so I'm excited this first
story's insane I ran it by you because
Oh oh my god I know your start leading
with this we're leading with this
because I think it's like the biggest
most insane story of the day horrified
fans react t I having his daughter's
hymen checked for virginity I can't yes
I read that right which I don't often do
virginity virginity oh no he's not
checking her virginity he's checking her
virginity I wish he was checking her
virginity you can do whatever you like
but not if you're TI's daughter the
rapper felt the wrath of almost everyone
on the internet Wednesday after he
bragged about regularly having a doctor
check his daughter's hymen to confirm
her virginity I literally during an
interview with the podcast ladies like
us the Atlanta musician boasted that
he's positive his daughter hasn't had
sex because quote we have yearly trips
to the gynecologist to check her hymen
implying that if she were sexually
active the membrane wouldn't be intact
quote I will say as of her 18th birthday
her hymen is still in town said of the
long debunked method of checking
virginity the 39 year old musician even
went so far as to describe how he
convinces his daughter to waive her
privacy rights during the annual exams
the doctor is like you know sir I have
to in order to share information I'm
like deja they want you to sign this
contest so we can share the information
is there anything you would not want me
to know see doc ain't no problem the
backlash was Swift with many calling out
his comments as inappropriate as well as
just plain uninformed yeah yeah yeah I'm
just like I would so how old is she now
is she's 18 well now that she's 18 she
is no longer a minor so she can she can
somehow like she could say no but then
her dad would like assume that she lost
her virginity and I don't know what
would happen like her chastity belt
would fall off and shrivel into a milli
pieces like what this poor girl like I
can't even get over what like also just
so hypocritical because t IM sure is
like always rapping about like [ __ ]
[ __ ] and like meanwhile your 18 year
old daughter what if she is like a high
school sweetheart and like wants to lose
her virginity to him like and you're
gonna stop that memory for her i just
like it's not it's not right this is so
inappropriate like it goes without
saying the backlash has been Swift and
very warranted and I hope that he learns
that I hope that he realizes oh this is
like not normal thing to do also be like
I just really like my heart goes out to
the daughter hey because her dad comes
with her to the gyno but B because now
everybody knows and see the whole world
talk about her hymen and her membrane oh
he can't also like going to the guy
knowing your teens he's like I didn't go
to the gyno until I was like 21 because
I didn't think that I had to and then I
remember I told you guys and you were
like are you [ __ ] kidding you have to
go and I was like oh [ __ ] so then I
wouldn't accept any like a daunting
experience like you're in the stirrups
and like oh my god I like things get
wild things get wild like imagine your
dad is in another room I hope it in
other room he better not be there when
the doctors like everyone had stirrups
he's out like thinking honestly I
remember the first time I went to the
gyno I like came back and I was like
talking to my friends I was like holy
[ __ ] like I feel like not enough people
talk about like the things that go down
in the gyno like it's crazy like
obviously makes sense that they need to
do these things like it's wild it's very
uncommon it's very uncomfortable they're
there physically it's just wild so it's
like imagine not only like a man but
your father like just I literally like
this is probably my worst nightmare yeah
no I mean you don't have to worry about
it because because we don't have a dad
so thanks thanks dad
this is really cherish this this needs
to stop and I hope that the daughter is
okay like ya know I'd like I'm honestly
praying her during this time because
this can't be easy like just like the
press about now everyone's talking about
her hymen and remembering and her
virginity I can that we should switch
the conversation to her virginity like
is she still vegetarian oh my god I
think is she still virgin I was like I
don't think that that is our business I
don't think and I don't say Joe there
are big
but I also don't think it's his business
TI definitely not like it you let your
daughter make her own choices and then
she's going to the gyno she's obviously
you know making sure everything's okay
so she seems to have a good head on her
shoulder right here right craziness
I'm shocked I hope that like this put
him in his place alright I feel like
it's not like I feel like he said Oh
everyone's so stupid oh I don't know I
haven't seen anything I haven't heard of
response to the back I haven't heard her
sponsor like that's just what I knew he
just needs to take some time like be
reading what people are saying like an
in-depth you know and like thoughts on
it not just people screaming at him yeah
I'm and understand why it's just like so
inappropriate yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
just I can't get over it
so it was the craziest story of the day
switching gears a little bit I'm sorry
pretty crazy story switching gears I
wish actually claudia was here because
she would probably say like something so
funny she would die about that story
yeah I'm in oh my got a fever
um the Met Gala 2020 theme has been
revealed
oh and Meryl Streep's going to co-chair
for the first time ever because nothing
says fashion like Meryl Streep so no one
ever Meryl Streep joins other stars like
Emma Stone and lin-manuel Miranda on the
chair committee Wow
fashion fans wait no more the 2020 Met
Gala had been revealed that's a sick on
people's part the 2020 Met Gala had been
revealed and the it's okay this sentence
doesn't even make what is the name the
theme is quote about time fashion and
duration I don't get it I never get it
yeah I would dress has a clock I think
the New York Times describes it as quote
inspired in part by the novels of
Virginia Woolf and the theories of the
earliest early 20th century French
philosopher Henri Bergson who's
admittedly somewhat obscure but also
important musings on time posited it as
a constantly mutating stream rather than
a series of discrete moments
I'm so confused I feel like everyone's
gonna dress up like Marie Antoinette
nothing says fashion like a constantly
mutating stream this sounds like oh I
guess time this has been interpretation
like history yeah Marie Antoinette
that's like the vibe I'm getting like
famous couples throughout history oh my
god I stink okay it could be interpreted
by you could be interpreted like that
and I feel as the
if Anna ever wanted the theme to be
famous couples throughout history she
couldn't do just that you know it's a
little too on the news so she would have
to go with like musings about time and
history but then I feel like Drew
Barrymore would have been on the
committee I agree the committee's a
little weird to me yeah they're on Team
Emma Stone lin-manuel um also because I
wanted to know who the designers on the
committee are this year because that
will tell you like a little bit of
Mataji last year vibe right um and this
year it's and it was Brandon Maxwell and
he dressed Lady gaga and oh yeah Barry
camp this year it's Louie Vuitton
artistic director Nicholas Carrie Anna
Wintour lin-manuel Miranda I'm a stone
and Meryl Streep okay so I guess it's
just a Louis Vuitton affair with Louie
Vuitton is having like a moment
especially Nikolaj oh that's how you
pronounce it from Emma Chamberlain's
videos and Virgil yeah exactly really
having a moment they're really having a
moment
like I'm they do every custom dress now
however and I'm excited about the end
I'm excited about the mecha as much as
like one can be excited about that yeah
I can't get that excited about a month
I'm sorry
but I was I am I was interested by what
the theme would be Jimmy Choos camp was
such an amazing theme like it was
campers and his counselors but it was
also candy and I just feel like everyone
was satisfied and it was everyone did an
incredible job with it but I will say
like last year at the Met Gala the
celebs who came dressed in Louboutin I
thought were some of the most
underwhelming but like what I think of I
don't know who else went except for
sophie Turner and Joe Jonas and I
thought that they looked amazing I
thought they looked amazing but like
they weren't they looked amazing because
they are amazing I don't know I actually
really liked what they wore who else did
they dress I don't know
see not memorable so I don't know but I
do see Louboutin time Louie Vuitton is
like time timeless like they can do like
I feel like Louie Vuitton is not really
cut out for camp I don't know when I
think of bluetongue dresses and Claudia
excited pest it's like what you're gonna
come in like a brown LV right yes right
but then you go look at Sophie Turner's
wedding gown and you understand right
but when I heard she was wearing a
little the time wedding dress I was like
oh she's burying like the print as a
dress oh my gosh all I can think about
yeah which is why I'm not
Nicholai Nicholai oh yeah and sorry
Nikhil I guess Carrie that's the chair
yeah right
sorry I learned so much from Emma from
Emma how's your girl snitched chamberlin
she's good she's [ __ ] killing it like
she has every amazing partnership in the
world it's truly the why all this thing
ever like she has she's a new synapse at
Ceres now I've subscribed to it I
haven't watched yet she has a series
with target on the target YouTube
channel and she goes to target with
celebrities in the shop for stuff so she
did one with Brad Gretzky and he likes
styled her and he was like so cute and
then she did one with Angela Kinsey from
the office and it was just like so cute
and like you know whatever just
everything everything she does is just
it's like the world can't get over that
they have someone like Emma Chamberlain
till they just ask her to do everything
that could kind of tap into her market
do you know what I mean yeah I watched
one of her videos because you're so
inspired by her and I'm so inspired by
you right and it was the one where she
went through shopping and did like she
styled Steph and I and I found it to be
very interesting and I totally get oh I
watched that one too I found that
incredibly interesting just to see how
she would style stuff because like I
would never I would never look so that
was cool yeah and she definitely has
style and I think as Derek Blasberg
who's calling her like an accidental
fashion icon kid I think yeah she is an
accidental fashion icon because like she
is she didn't know fashion from [ __ ] and
like now she's going to Paris for like
Fashion Week with Louis Vuitton and she
just and she's loving it also and she's
like open about it she's like I'm still
learning about it but like I love
fashion blah blah blah and like I'd love
to see where she is in like five years
yeah definitely back to the Met because
people are talking about like what they
think it could be interpreted as Hannah
Luba makes a great point she said do we
think that people will be dressed in
current iterations of trends from
different eras that'd be cool that'd be
cool
like I want some like Renaissance vibes
I feel like a lot of people if that is
the case if they're going like but then
is it gonna be like someone's like from
like the 80s with like leg warmers I
feel like people would lean into the 90s
because like everyone loves dressing or
like the 20s Roaring 20's flapper right
but that's also like our interpret like
yeah yeah that's I don't know I think I
might still be a clock just in case if
someone dresses up as a clock like I
think one person will dress has a clock
I'm saying it now some like someone
dressed by mosquito a hundred and fifty
percent Katy Perry will be going as a
clock I'm curious to see I feel like
Taylor Swift will go this year maybe
because she's like out and about now
yeah
interesante maybe that's where she'll
meet her next
oh no she's in a relationship I just
always think of the MEK out when I think
of her at the mouth I think of Tom
Hiddleston because remember that fan who
predicted that they wouldn't eat at the
Met Gala not predicted but she wrote fan
fiction this girl on her tumblr wrote
like fan fiction about Taylor Swift that
she was gonna meet Tom Hiddleston at the
Met Gala and later they would start
dating what yeah she just like wrote it
for fun it wasn't a prediction or
anything but it turned out to be right
that is like truly one of the weirdest
things I didn't know that yeah well she
was right it was short-lived but it
happened okay or Lady Gaga will be the
clock great call Jess gasps very
interesting vinegar would be a clock um
well we'll see you in six months
um yeah can't wait till I come back to
this conversation and be like wow we
were so wrong but you know what the
chairs the celeb chairs like I feel as
though our interesting choices because
it's a little boring
very boring I mean Meryl Streep Emma
Stone lin-manuel Miranda like Oh like
iconic great but you don't have that
like Lady Gaga that person like Emma
Stone always it's like so chic but safe
always safe all of them are always safe
and laughs but let I think that they
just can't top last year's like last
year they had like such epic people that
Harry Styles they had Lady gaga I'm like
I don't remember who third of them I
think I think they need one
you know character in there yeah but
they don't have it no not that I'm maybe
they're trying to go for like a timeless
like not boring but boring BEC ala where
like everyone just looks like glam and
like she said of camp yeah exactly
well also what I learned I learned a lot
actually from the last Met Gala um that
where I was wrong what that we're always
wrong oh that we're always know but like
we're also sort of right um know what I
learned is how much it's based on the
exhibit at oh yeah oh yeah and so when
you look at the dresses on the red
carpet compared to what's in the Met and
a lot starts to make more sense and what
I also learned is that I am like so
ahead of the time because my wedding
dress was camp like and the three tool
tier that was something that was
happening in the exhibit and by the way
when I bought that dress I bought it
last August I never seen anything like
it I've never seen anything I just like
put it on and it was meant for me but
then it really that's shaped that
silhouette became like the shape of the
season like Kacey Musgraves at the grand
yeah yeah um and it just like made me
feel really cool I mean that's the
coolest feeling ever is being it before
the trend right and it was like it
is not risky because I loved it so much
but it was like I wasn't your average
wedding dress no so I didn't think
anyone would like have negative things
to say but it was an interesting choice
yeah my hidden thing didn't take on like
a life of its own right and that it was
like I could if I had been invited to
the Met Gala that year you could have
more before I could have just worn my
wedding dress I'm in right and see ya
hunting camp bride ya feel like dyed it
pink
oh my god you should I should and then
like get invited to a gala yeah but
don't have to be worth it yeah okay I'm
definitely gonna wear both of my wedding
dresses again like at some point in my
life oh we had a Friday - if you ever
want to borrow one like let me know okay
the second one would look really good
maybe like for my wedding oh my god
totally
I imagine - like warrior dress you cut
like you totally should yeah okay next
story was a snitch requested story
because Shay Mitchell has revealed her
be a girl's name Shay Mitchell has
revealed her daughter's name less than a
month after giving birth
Atlas Noah is the name quote in my 32
years of life I thought I had seen a lot
of places experienced a lot of things
met a lot of people and felt loved then
came you she penned in an Instagram
caption on Wednesday truth is I had no
idea was capable of loving anything like
this before you arrived you wonder if
that's just something people say but
it's as if the chemical makeup of my
entire body and soul change the minute
that we met that is so sweet
so the baby girl's name is Atlas
beautiful name very cool beautiful name
like that's why I just want you to
choose a story because like I just like
didn't know that Jay Mitchell like had
such good taste
honestly like I think out this is such a
beautiful name and it's like not like so
like trying to it's so out there of
trying to be different it's just like
such a beautiful name like Atlas Noah
like it just I'm just so impressed by
her name choice because she checks all
the boxes of like celebrity name
interesting you know it's not like
Rachel Sarah a but if I met someone
named Alice I'd be like wow like I want
to get to know you like you're
interesting 100% and it's also timeless
like the Met Gala see maybe maybe Atlas
will be going to the Met Gala now she
Mitchell has ever been I feel like she
will be a man feel like she's like she's
one of like the top influencers of
Instagram and also she's had a nice
career so like she seems like a shoo-in
I totally agree she's never gone though
no interesting well maybe this is her
year with her bed
this is really cool I like this trend of
good name choices and interesting and
different and first and I feel like I'm
gonna see this name rise and the baby
name hundred-percent and like it's gonna
be because of Shay Mitchell me it made
me want to name my kid Atlas like I
can't leave I'm never even thought of
that
hmm it's a great name and it's also um
gender-neutral you know he had it um I
gotta find so if I was a teacher and I
was like looking at the class list and I
saw like an Atlit Atlas Mitchell what's
a baby Noah Noah Babel I think babble
babble Alice no babble like I have no
idea whether that's a girl or a boy yeah
and also if you were a counselor which
you are the winner in both yeah yeah
well the bunks are co-ed so no yes I
would know um very very cool thank you
for suggesting that story counselor
snitch welcome I just really want to
talk about X nu Lee wanted I know like
che probably watches every day so like
oh I wanted to commend her on her name
choice yeah
very very cool okay next story is
debunking some rumors because last week
we reported that Kylie Jenner and Drake
were like an item potentially and as of
this week like the rumors are picking up
even more steam however today he has put
out an article debunking these rumors
and it makes me feel as though it's
someone from the Kardashian oh of course
it is putting it out and it's about the
Kardashians it's true
Kylie Jenner and Drake have been
sparking romance rumors lately after a
series of hangouts but not everything is
always what it seems
while the beauty mogul was spotted
attending the Grammy winners birthday
and Halloween parties in recent weeks a
source close to Drake tells a news that
the celebs are not romantically involved
it was source close to Drake I guess
they didn't want to pin down Kylie cuz
I'm even know it was Kylie the only
notes coming from the mouth of Kris
Jenner right because I feel like if this
was potentially true he just like
wouldn't write anything if they didn't
out but quote Kylie and Drake are not
romantic they have always been good
friends and have been hanging out more
that Kylie is single and Drake is in
town at his house at Calabasas I heard
he was in Houston but okay quote it's a
convenient friendship but it's strictly
platonic
Drake is notorious for flirting with all
of his girlfriends and him and Kylie
have a great dynamic okay we'll see
about that
we said Kylie and Drake are into the
same things and Drake will quote come
over and chill with Kylie and daughter
stormy Webster from time to time
it's an applet ani that's not platonic
anyways okay we the source ads they
aren't hooking up but kylie is enjoying
having him around okay this is making me
think more than ever that they are an
item
I'm honestly is ship it my ship to the
end like now I can see it all like who
them at the back out I also ship Kylie
and Travis I didn't want them to get
back to you I know me too because for
the love of store me for the love of
sort me but like Adem at the makalah
them at the Grammys like they were
everything they are everything I know
but like everything she did was Travis
she can do with Drake on such a bigger
scale no I think it would be the same
scale cuz and I don't know they were
just amazing and now it's like if she
and Drake start dating like so suit like
so publicly so soon then there's a no no
hope for her and Travis and like no I
know you're you're right but like psych
drink you know I'm so conflicted no I
know also I just need to talk about so
I'm gonna go Chloe and drink that data
but yeah also like isn't there like
Drake drama but no wait I'm straight
drama but I'm looking past the Drake
drama because clearly everyone else
looking yes wait I wanted to talk about
did you see that Kim and Kanye were in
New York yesterday and they like stepped
out of their hotel she's in that like
Jean item it was like an outfit that I
can't honestly explain it was different
but Kanye like looked so hot really you
see it I'm just like scrolling on my
explore page like it was just you know I
paparazzi photos but I thought maybe you
had seen them because I keep was like in
this like blue like velvet like suit
moment with like boots and like he I've
never thought he was hot but I was like
oh my god
he looks so whatever I got it just like
that interesting yeah do you see that
Kim posted that like she's been in New
York a lot lately and she loves it here
no I know like maybe she should get an
apartment and then I come on this
morning show called an apartment right
oh yeah oh he's staying in hotels
they're always there oh saying like at
the Bowery Hotel yeah they're like I
don't actually know any hotel in New
York but like if someone asked me where
to stay here I wouldn't have an answer
what would you say the plaza no no like
I don't know I'd be like well where are
you yeah but like where do you need to
be and then I just like go to Google I
think I would say the Bowery Hotel if
someone asked because um it's in a good
location it's cool and then you get to
go to the restaurant
and celeb stay there all the time and
the restaurant in the hotel like doesn't
accept reservations unless you're
staying at the hotel okay
yeah and it's a delicious feast Eve I
like what if someone's just like a
regular person no I think a regular
person who's like not interested in
celebrities yeah like it's just like it
needs to come to New York for okay then
it depends what they need to be here for
in what part of town exactly okay that's
what I said yeah but I think generally
speaking like Bowery Hotel it's like
everyone has like to be downtown yeah
but it's in a good location yeah yeah
I've never really been in like a hotel I
don't have been in a hotel room or like
you could you like if you're like like
Upper East Side like the Regency or the
mark is where everyone stays for the
Mecca and the Carlyle in the Carlyle
yeah yeah and then if you're up there
like the plaza up here like go
quintessential New York yeah yeah okay I
wonder what else is even any wedding
oh I stayed in a hotel room for your
wedding to remember there was a room in
my bridal suite for my wedding weekend
that had like two twin beds it was one
of the weirdest things I've ever done I
need first niche what that you slept in
my room yeah on your wedding night no
but like I was concussed like my husband
was so drunk and we had an extra bedroom
and like and everybody ditched me and I
was like at the after-party alone and I
had nowhere to go yeah I mean all I came
home at like different I feel ya know it
was like very it was great to wake up
next to the snitch not nice no sorry not
next door it's my husband next door to
this minute yes it was a big suite so it
was cool it was hilarious
okay fifth and final story are you ready
for it I'm ready for it cuz it's an
interesting bit of celebrity celebrity
and legal news Sandra Bullock and Ellen
DeGeneres are suing websites over fake
beauty ads Sandra Bullock and Ellen
DeGeneres are taking legal action
against websites that are using their
likenesses without permission the bird
box actress and daytime talk show host
both filed lawsuits in LA Superior Court
on Wednesday against john doe's 1
through 100 because it's unknown who is
behind the alleged fraud according to
the New York Times both stars claim the
websites have been spreading false
endorsements with fake advertisements
that include the pair promoting
anti-aging skincare and other beauty
products so I feel like I know what
they're talking about you know when you
scroll to the bottom of website said
it's like fake websites using celebrity
images like you got you to click yeah
well like I think that's what they're
fighting against but it sounds like
they're suing people but don't know who
they're suing exactly so how can you get
like it's gonna be a tough one
for them but I think it's just like them
putting your foot down yeah the
celebrity endorsement theft business
model is based on a scheme to trick
consumers into disclosing their credit
card under debit card information in
order to enroll them in costly programs
with undisclosed or poorly disclosed
recurring charges as for the products
typically include unsubstantiated claims
that the products will lead to dramatic
results one add bullet claim took a real
photo of her appearing on The Today Show
to promote a movie but was doctored to
become an endorsement for her new
skincare line Bullock has never had a
skincare line
oh so it's worse than oh yeah that's bad
yeah that is bad very bad I'm good I'm
glad I'm tired of seeing that crap like
you know what I either want a celeb
endorsement or I want nothing at all
yeah you know I don't want the last
thing I want is a fake celebrity
endorsement yeah well good for them I
hope that they can like to figure out
who it is because how can you see
someone if you don't have like their
bank account in their name yeah I don't
know but they must have a plan in action
if they're taking it to the courts to
the courts who was a Jennifer Garner and
and who Sandra Bullock Sandra Bullock
and Ellen DeGeneres okay on this later
I want a paragraph that would be funny
if after every episode of the show we
like put out a pop quiz you should do
those like pull like the poll no [ __ ]
I quit yeah on Instagram but you know
how you can ask the question it's like
which and so if you're wrong it tells
you're wrong if you're right it does
right you should do that we should do
that we should do that you know what you
should do you should check out Thursday
boots because it's Thursday today and we
gotta get boots on Thursday everybody's
looking to go over to wearing their
Thursday we're coming apart but we love
Thursday boots and we love Thursdays
here at the morning toast in general and
obviously Thursday boots is a brand that
is in tune with what's necessary because
they know how great it is to be Thursday
so you deserve more comfortable boots
without the high retail markups Thursday
boots is an investment in comfort
timeless styles and staples that will
last for years so I've gotten a few pair
of Thursday boots now and I have ones
that are like classics just like black
boots Claudia's over the knee boots that
she wears all the time or day boots I
got the cutest boots that like I need to
send to Cheryl blossom because they're
white
booties with cherries on them
they're just so [ __ ] they're so
[ __ ] they also come in black and
they're high-quality boots I wear those
boots like literally from the toast
until going out to dinner at night and
my feet don't hurt at all and I'm flat
footed so like that says a lot about the
comfort you would be and I would be
flat-footed because I'm a little grandma
yeah 100% he looks so cute
I do you look so cute it's just so
precious you look so precious okay you
okay and everyone needs a pair of
Thursday boots in their life especially
on a Thursday Thursday but boots
believes in year-round honest prices so
while they don't do sales or discounts
they're giving our listeners free
two-day shipping on their first order
and always offer free returns and
exchanges so you have nothing to lose
trying out a few pairs go to Thursday
boots calm / toast and you can have a
pair on your doorstep before next
Thursday
wow that's th urs da y vo OTS comm /
toast for free today shipping returns
and exchanges so Thursday boots it's
style it's comfort it's everything it's
quick it's quick so I can't like and
it's boot season out here like it's
gonna know I have got to get my boots
it is getting frosty Fry's Diaz he'll
like I love these blogger boots but
they're not kind of sustained every day
yeah so get your boots at Thursday boots
calm / totes love it sign-on welcoming
walk this way Chuck this way okay well
those were the past five stories Wow
do we have anything to like recap well I
didn't watch Real Housewives of Dallas
because I was so tired after dinner last
night you went out though it was good it
was chill it was chill it just like met
my friends for a drying just one drink
you said you were going to wine bar but
then I saw your Instagram you were
drinking a beer do you want to explain
oh yeah we were gonna go to I'm barber
then we didn't so we just went to this
random bar like by this girl's apartment
and then I got a glass of wine at the
bar and it truly tasted like ass and I
just I couldn't so that I got a beer got
it about by it I only oh now I had one
Bud Light and two shots of fireball
Wow Powerball doo-doo-doo - dude you're
such like a party girl I know it's like
I've always been like a partier but I
feel like in the past few months it's
gotten to a new level of partying you're
just like doing in a better smarter way
I feel because I feel like you always
used to like go all-in for like a
thing but yeah you're just like
expanding like you're you're going out
more probably drinking less each time
you go out but like that gives you
longevity that's true you know I don't
know about like the drinking less but
yeah well you look you don't look
hungover today so you cop no I wasn't
hung over today yeah because I said I
was I got to be up at 9:00 right cuz I
have to I have to coast so I purposely
didn't really get that drawn but also
like if you're getting like so back out
on a Wednesday there's a problem
birthday so your foot if I was like with
you celebrating that's something else
but like I went might met my friends for
a drink afterwards like from getting
blackout that's a problem yeah and I'm
or something like on weekends I just
feel like I've been like going out like
every night good you're young do it for
those of us who can't I know that's do
it for those of us who physically can't
drink without like losing three days off
their life and I feel like also it's
like once you like become an adult like
or start getting there it's like people
really like take the weekend seriously
so oh yeah really go out on Friday and
you really go out on side it's work hard
play hard for sure
yeah um there was one thing I wanted to
talk about yes today is an important day
because this is the last time we'll be
sitting here on the morning toast
without having the new Luke Holmes album
oh my god oh my god like I feel like
nobody's talking about it 11:11 make
wish I wish more people are talking
about that Luke Holmes is coming off an
album tomorrow
17 new songs seventeen new songs by Luke
Holmes like what are we gonna do I don't
know and it's just like it's like I feel
like we've been waiting for this for so
long but it's also like he really
learned like knows how to like quench
people's thirst because it's like he put
out his original out album then he put
out a deluxe one which had beautiful
creat like had songs that were just like
oh my god that are just quintessential
to the discography of Luke oh and then
it's like okay so like we got kind of
like two albums there whatever and then
you love Luke um so much and you
actually can go back to his first album
that he'd released before you probably
knew him and you get songs like you see
him and let the moon shine and the way
she rides like each song from his first
album like sounds like it could be
released as a single right now no I know
and then what do you do sometimes it's
so weird like I play Luke home as well I
like doing stuff around the house and
he's the only artist that when I sing
along to what his song that I find
myself harmonizing oh what I mean you
know I don't find I don't maybe it's cuz
I've heard him do different renditions
like in concerts stuff but I like will
go low and he goes high
is that weird is weird it's just cuz
there's so much like music there anyway
anyway so then it's like he gives you
those two he gives you those two and
it's like I wish T I won't check his
daughter's hymen anymore oh he's a good
one I wish I was for that as well and
then it's like okay it literally is like
the number one it he's like tied with
like Shania Twain or whatever yeah and
then he puts out the prequel so it's
like a mini like album and it's like pee
and in your dish ish and then you're
just like oh my god like here's more and
then he puts out the full one and it's
like I feel like he's just like
constantly giving us more and like he's
always just like dropping bangers I'm
like on he's like Instagram he'll just
like post like an IG TV of like a new
song right and then you just like in the
random like middle of the winter you get
beer never broke my heart oh my the fall
you get one too many oh my god and it's
like I it's oh it it's just like I can't
understand like how Luke Holmes is like
such a good songwriter cuz it's like
it's not even just like about like the
songs are good and they're catchy it's
like he's they're so smart
do you know what I mean even though it
is about drinking beer but like he makes
it like into like five four three two
one - money how has nobody come up with
that before or nothing like a beer can
like a beer can and a beer so many
double entendres the song long way that
is that's a long ways right no I'm
thinking there's long way okay
whatever there's one song specifically
it's like it could literally be two
completely different songs because
there's so many double entendres yeah
it's me it's amazing so I'm just so
excited for what 17 new songs is gonna
do for us I just like and it's like he's
like the one artist I'm not worried
about like won't be able to top himself
like he's not screams I'm actually
worried it's like Golden Hour how the
[ __ ] do you top that no whatever but
like I feel like Luke Holmes is just
getting better and better do this for
the rest of his life like release these
songs and also all of these songs what I
feel like it's like they could have been
on any album for a second third like it
all worked together where I feel like
with a lot of artists like maybe like
Kacey Musgraves or Taylor Swift it's
like every album is like a moment in
time and that you have to be like this
perfect package together yeah where it's
like he's just like hit after hit after
hit
and also like I can't believe how big
he's gotten like the places that he
performs like it takes people that what
were air was at that stadium 19,000
people oh yeah I saw that
the Tacoma Dome yeah he's playing to
change the name to the Tacoma Dome oh
he's playing his first actual stadium
like I think in North Carolina that's
where he's from soon it's like Joe how
long it takes people to like get to the
stadium level and like he did he did in
actually two years we should go like I
would take a weekend trip to North
Carolina we should go to Luke oh
absolutely go Combs
oh yeah it's I feel like I don't get to
see him enough yeah he doesn't come to
New York and it's just like annoying
when we were at Liv method like Matt was
asking us if we'd been to any concerts
recently and we were like no because we
mostly go during the summer
cuz it's country but I feel like when I
was young and I was your age um I used
to go to like all these like little
shows of artists that I just really like
I was thinking because I remember I saw
cam at like Highline Ballroom like four
years ago just because I like some of
her youth and I just wanted to see her
live like we just need to go to more
shows no I know but like I look at
concerts - all the time like ah yeah a
master and I'm I just don't see them I
just need a seat because I'm a grandma
no I know that's all I need this
standing is just but seats are rare yeah
especially for the small chair a
dime-a-dozen yes like Highline Ballroom
and Hammerstein you got sittin
Hammerstein hammer shine Webster no
seats so I'm excited for a new music
Friday tomorrow for Luke Holmes album
obviously also tonight I'm recording a
podcast episode oh yeah with Tonya rad
for tomorrow's episode and I'm so
excited she's also a new music I've been
getting so many new music suggestions I
feel like you and her if you have the
exact same I know every time she does
the song of the day thing I'm like oh I
know it yeah also I just want to talk
about the new do a lip a song because
it's incredible do all of us amazingly
talented artist she's had so many great
hits like obviously um rules new rules
um and electricity electricity's
beautiful so I wanna kiss one kiss was a
great Bop but it wasn't like it's great
sorry and everyone loves it but I don't
know what I just didn't feel like I need
to play it on repeat repeat repeat at my
house but her new song come on start now
don't start now it's just like she's
she's veering into icon territory but
this yes and it's like I'm so excited
for her and animal and like I get why
she won the Grammy for Best New Artist
I'm 2% and for her in Anwar yeah did you
see her before I also love the way she
dances because she was born yeah I saw
her she's always
meaning she's introducing new dances oh
no I didn't see her perform like don't
start now but she was at the Amazon
Prime concert when Taylor was so I saw
her performance in like I remember me
and cauti were like a shocked it beat
how beautiful she was be such an amazing
dancer like literally like she could
have been like pro on Dancing with the
Stars
yeah and how good of a singer she is
like she really is like just a triple
threat what's the third one dancing
acting okay I don't know about the
acting but I think we're all actresses
except for me I'm the worst actress of
all time
um but ya know she's like she is totally
gonna be an icon and she's also just
kind of at the beginning of her career
too which is wild yeah wild why I could
see really I mean obviously she'll be
primed but I feel like for a long time
she's been mixed up with like Charli XCX
bebe Rexha like they're all kind of the
same but like she's just oh my god she's
out here no yeah she's she's no Charli
XCX
everyone do yourselves a favor listen to
Luke Holmes all day today get excited
for the album it's gonna be [ __ ]
incredible industry mystery industry
stream what you see is what you get at
midnight blue combs sponsors my favorite
either mm even though I'm leaving yeah
this one's for you this one's for you
just like gets me every single [ __ ] I
know every single [ __ ] time like I
could be sleeping and it could come out
and I'm like I'm gotten you know I'm
gotten this because it's just like this
one's for you you know I mean it's
amazing it's amazing and even though I'm
leaving just because you know yeah those
ones are just like so sad that would be
or never broke my heart
we were never broke my heart obviously
but like there's more to that there's
more to Holmes and just if you're never
broke my heart yeah totally agreed thank
you so much counselor snitch for joining
us tomorrow's episode reminder is
podcast only it's gonna be incredible
though like literally I think we're
recording it tonight at midnight because
she like lamb so late but I'll do
anything to get the premium content and
to hang out with Tania rad no she's so
[ __ ] cool I'm really excited to see
her get jealous and then on Monday
snitch is back on the toast so don't
miss her too much for like my last yeah
for your last time it's gonna be like a
farewell to the snitch yeah it'll be
like really that's so sad I'm gonna cry
the whole time I love to see you cry
Tuesday Claudia's back then we head to
Nashville for the CMAs I have my dress
it is so [ __ ] small and tight
so like pray for me um and yeah it's
gonna be a great weekend of good stuff
good stuff thank you everyone for
watching make sure you subscribe tell a
friend follow us on Instagram at Jackie
O listen to the snatchler if you do get
more gosh where I'm at 97.5 K please get
me to 100 K we're getting these we're
getting this master to 100 K it's her
it's her farewell gift
it's my parting gift for from the toast
so please follow at margrock show while
you're there head over to add Jackie O
problems subscribe to us on YouTube woo
my crowns falling off Oh
subscribe on YouTube like this video
comment tag a friend follow us on
Instagram at the morning toast we are
the Millennial morning show going live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time it's all the news that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast and you know
what you'll be better off for it because
it's pertinent to the situation and
listen to the satchel ER and listen to
the snatchler check out our other tienen
chose mood with Warren Elizabeth new
episode with fellow it girl Claudius
loose key is up right now we've got an
episode of date night up right now so
much content so little time picture I'm
not calm session morning toast up right
now so much fun time so I'm gonna chill
of time such premium [ __ ] love you guys
love you guys
you